most people half of what they thought
today is the same things they thought
yesterday about themselves about their
life about the business that's why most
people's lives don't change very much
but if you wake up
and you start realizing i'm living in a
home an emotional home i don't want you
can change it
see because everybody's got if you've
got a billion dollars check this out if
you had a billion dollars
but the habitual emotions you go back to
are frustrated pissed off
then your life is called frustrated and
pissed off it doesn't matter how much
money you have
write this down please the quality of my
life is the quality of my habitual
emotions
the quality of my entire life
is nothing but the quality of my
habitual emotions whatever habits of
emotion wherever my emotional home is i
will find a way to get back there and
until i change that i'm gonna have a
problem
how many of you see people in some part
of the world
in my country for example you'll see
this in the middle of america where
there's certain places they have
cyclones all the time or maybe down in
new orleans or places where every few
years you get a huge storm that wipes
out everybody right on the coast there
but then two years later it happens
again they rebuild it happens again how
many have ever thought to yourself why
don't these people move
and why don't they move guys because
it's what their condition they call that
home i don't want to leave my home it's
what i know
it's easy to see when it's somebody else
and it's physical it's harder to see
when it's yourself and it's emotional
because we have an emotional home some
of you grew up in a really tough
environment i did too pretty brutal
environment
very painful environment part of i am
who i am is because i didn't want to
suffer how to find answers and because i
suffered so much i don't want you to
ever suffer if i can do anything about
it i can't control it but i can help
massively
but it's only because i suffered so much
don't want anybody else to
but think about it
most people suffer even when they're
successful
listen if you're successful and you're
not fulfilled
that's the ultimate failure
if you got people that love you and
you're not feeling joyous and alive
something's wrong and you know what it
is you got an old home you're used to
maybe the home you're used to is not a
very happy home it's a home of worry a
home of frustration home of anger a home
a feeling everything is unjust and so
you find a way to get back home
using whatever the environment you can
use
how many of you know somebody who's
always pissed off about something
how many of you know somebody
who is always worried
how many of you know someone
who is not really funny
but they think they are
and they cracked himself up telling
stupid joe how many know something like
this who cracks themselves up and they
laugh so much that even though it's not
funny you find yourself laughing too
these people have different emotional
homes some people's home is anger
they'll always find something to be
angry about
it's what they're used to
it's their conditioning so even when the
storm comes in and messes up their life
they go right back to that same
wouldn't it be nice to upgrade your home
your emotional home where you live
what if you could live every day with a
vast majority of the emotions you had
were
joy
and gratitude and love and appreciation
even in the middle of covet even when
somebody does something unjust
compassion
playfulness
what would that feel like if you were in
those states every day
90 95 percent of the time when you
weren't you got out of it quick
you can make that change this weekend
and i'm not exaggerating an ounce i'm
not saying you're going to be perfect
and never have a negative feeling
because negative feelings are sometimes
a signal to make us change but most
people are negative ceiling and they
just hang on to it and keep living with
it find other things to be negative
about
that will never give you what you want
the money won't do it the
acknowledgement of others won't do it
everything you think will do it will not
do only one thing will do it you drawing
a line the santa making the most
important decision of your life that
you're going to live in a beautiful
state no matter what
because life is too short
to suffer
we have a choice listen to me
pain is sometimes part of life but
suffering is a choice
but for most of us not a choice because
we have the habit of suffering being
stressed being worried being
frustrated being pissed off
and because we're wired that way
that's the muscle we built
but if we rebuild our home here so it's
even more magnificent then you can have
the life that you desire and deserve and
you do it one weekend only if you give
your all and push enough energy out
while you're doing it while you're
learning let's start by looking
backwards in 2021
now this is going to seem like wow
thanks for bringing me here to depress
me today dean but i would love for you
and write this down i would love for you
to write down and think through what are
the regrets
failures
missed opportunities
botches mistakes whatever you want to
call it what are the regrets failures
mistakes or missed opportunities that
happened in 2021
i really want you to think about that
what went wrong where did you
procrastinate
where did you waste time
where did you miss an opportunity
what did you try and didn't work
really take a moment and write this down
this is part of setting up 2022 for the
win you can't know where you're going to
go until you figure out where you've
been
as we write these down and and i and i
see so many of you writing and i see
some of you not we all screwed up and
made did things wrong
congratulations for being human
congratulations for being human
if you were listen
if you're on a quest to be a better
version of you i promise mistakes are
going to be made along the way
if you don't want to wear someone else's
name on the back of your jersey if you
want to live life to the fullest if you
don't want to see a video at the end of
your life of the woman that you could
have been then we are going to make
mistakes we are going to fail that means
that you are moving forward if you don't
have any mistakes in 2021 then i'm sorry
you didn't try enough you're playing it
safe and nothing is going to change i
want you to be disturbed with inaction
you want another level of life we got to
screw up we got to get out and step off
the path we got to get out of the norm
we got to get away from what's
comfortable you want to you want to take
the island you have to burn the boats
and in that journey you are going to
mess up you are going to fail you are
going to do things wrong
sarah break blakely the the founder of
spanx who just sold for billions of
dollars i remember one of her stories
about her dad used to ask her all the
time what did you fail at today and if
she said nothing he's like well you
didn't push yourself
think about that philosophy
right what went wrong
what didn't work
because that is the building block to
who we're supposed to be
and this year i'm going to encourage you
to fail more
fail faster
fail bigger
be disturbed in a bigger way because
here's what i know if you fail up
something bigger you learn
bigger
lessons it's like if if you say ah
nothing really went wrong in 2021. then
you're talking out of both sides of your
mouth you're here because you want more
but you really didn't put the effort in
in 2021 you played it safe how is
playing it safe working out for you you
want to tell your maker at the end of
your life i played it safe how's that
going to feel you're going to want to
redo you're going to want to do it over
the things that you wrote down that
failed didn't work you procrastinated
what's one thing you learned from each
one of the things that you said you
failed what's one thing you learned i
tried marketing this way it didn't work
i tried this with my relationship it
didn't work i tried that diet it didn't
work but what did work out of it you
might have figured out what doesn't work
for you i need to exercise in a variety
trying to do the same thing over and
over doesn't work me i tried counting
calories one time to get in like ideal
shape i can't do it i'm not the person
that's going to figure out i need a diet
where i can just look at stuff and order
it or i don't mean a diet like i'm
dieting i just have a regular way of
eating exercise i need to mix up my
cardio i can't just run on a treadmill
every day if i try to do i get so bored
i quit but if i go run the mountain take
a job do the stairmaster do the uh do i
have the peloton it's amazing by the way
do the peloton bike go play racquetball
go play squash or pickleball if i mix
that up i'll do cardio five days a week
if i try to just sit on a treadmill
every day it doesn't work for me so i
know that can't work i also know in my
relationship
that if i don't if i work so much that i
don't look my wife in the eye every day
and ask her about our day and catch up
and have that time with my wife and i my
wife goes to bed a little bit sad
and i realize that that doesn't work for
me i don't care that my business is big
and i have hundreds of employees and i
i've got a million things going on
my wife the love of my life if i go home
and just kind of dismiss her day because
my stuff was bigger
then that woman doesn't look at me at
the way that i love the way she looks at
me so that was a little bit of a fail
because we went down the road and i was
starting to go down that road i got so
busy i was running tony's company
running my company writing a new book
flying all over and i'm like baby i love
you got some big stuff going on thank
you and i'd go to bed and i watched my
wife go to set go to bed sad for about
two months
and i didn't know why i'm like damn
what's going on because it was all about
me
i realized where i felt all i got to do
i'm so lucky it's so easy to be married
to my wife i just got to stop and go i
had a busy day babe but i missed you
what's up with you
and if we have 15 minutes of that talk
man
i got a
i got a
amazing wife that looks at me like
it's just the greatest thing on earth it
was a fail
until i figured out what went wrong and
what i learned from it and i shifted so
i want you to think about this i want
you to take two minutes right now and i
just want you to write down yeah you
failed but what could you have learned
from it marketing that way doesn't work
talking to my husband that way doesn't
work this kind of exercise doesn't work
but what did i learn i should mix it up
i should talk different i should listen
more i should market different i need to
get more capabilities i got to dig back
into the course those that you got
accelerated success formula got to get
back in the course project next got to
get back in the course got to get a
coach i don't know what it is but you'll
learn something from it i want you to
take those lessons now you can go back
you got your notes you know what we're
talking about you can go deeper on this
i want you to take those lessons
you have to take the things that went
wrong
identify them we have to jot down what
we can learn from them you ready for
this we want to take the things we
learned and i want you to have like this
hypothetical line drawn in the sand 2021
lives on this side 2022 lives on this
side
you take the things you learn from the
failures and you bring them over the
line
and you leave all the other crap in
2021.
picture it this way someone's i read
this once someplace and it stuck with me
and i'm going to paraphrase it now but
think about you have a house and it's
all shelves or a building with all
shelves and it's all the things from
2021
and you're taking what serves you
you're taking the lessons learned and
you're putting them in a suitcase and
you're carrying them and then the place
catches on fire you let all the crap
that didn't work burned down in 2021 you
just carry out of the house or across
the finish line the things you learned
does that make sense because so many of
you are carrying regrets you're carrying
things that went wrong yes some of you
screwed up on relationships welcome to
being human some of you screwed up in
your business welcome to being human
some of you didn't eat right you didn't
take care of your health you know you
had diabetes you still ate like
okay you did it you want to regret and
carry that forever or you want to leave
it in the past so you can become the man
or the woman you were destined to be we
can't carry all the [ __ ] from our past
and try to become who we're meant to be
we've got to find a line in the sand
dennis you're feeling me on this one and
we gotta leave it in yesterday
that's how you identify
where you are
and where you need to bring it with you
the key to success
is look at successful people
and do what they do
and look at people who are just living a
mediocre life
and don't do what they do
okay
really because that's what i did
i watched
and i studied people who were successful
i was born in liberty city
and over town i was raised living city
in overtown
and
i had friends
who lived on miami beach that i met
and i stayed around them i met them
while going to work with my mother who
was doing domestic work cleaning homes
on miami beach
and i heard one of the the families that
she worked for
mr sudersky say to his son you want to
be successful he said watch successful
people and do what they do and you
accomplish the things that i have
accomplished
and
watch poor people
and don't do what they do
that was some good advice he gave his
son i overheard the conversation i took
it to heart
i remember reading something about
jackie onassis
somebody asked her if you lost all of
your money
how would you get your wealth back
and i love her answer
she said i would go to the the most
expensive restaurant
and and move my table as close as i
possibly could
to people that are in there having
conversations
primarily wealthy people
order a glass of water
and ease drop
on their conversations
and in two years
i will get all my wealth back
whoa
that's something to think about
see
the reason that
a lot of people are panicked right now
and and feeling anxious be anxious for
nothing you're listening to the wrong
people
right now
you want to be selective of who you
listen to
right now
you want to get around the right people
that lift your spirit that inspire you
that make you feel good that make you
laugh
and and remind you
that you have greatness in you
that you can overcome this that let you
know
that that you were made for this
see
when you think about life
people say it
it's challenging yes it is challenging
life is for our growth and development
you you cannot develop growth without
being challenged
faith
not tested can't be trusted in life you
will always
be tested
stuff's gonna happen to you you're gonna
lose people you're gonna get sick
tragedies accidents all kinds of stuff
will be thrown at you
but it doesn't matter about those things
what matter most is about you
how you handle it
and see most people are pessimistic they
they look at a difficult situation
and
they they they give up and they
surrender they become negative
pessimistic people
they can look at opportunities
and they'll say nah
it won't work
why because they're pessimistic
and optimists will look at difficult
situations
and they'll look at
obstacles
and optimists will say you know what
if something is shut down that means
that something else has opened up
danger oh danger but also
opportunity
it's a different perspective
and then they start working to make that
happen with that vision that they're
holding in their mind you were born to
do something great with your life that
you're extraordinary listen to me that
you're enough that you're special that
you're favored that you're chosen
regardless of where you come from
regardless of what you've been carrying
with you some of you come in here today
and you know what you've even thought of
harming yourselves
maybe you're even proud of the fact you
haven't killed yourself but every day
some of us are killing ourselves with
the shame we carry from something we've
done some humiliation some fear we put
this gun to our head every day that
tells us we're not enough we're not
strong enough pretty enough smart enough
favored enough that we're doomed and we
carry these guns in our head every day
that shame us that take our confidence
from us that steal our joy it's like a
knife we you don't have to kill yourself
because you do it every day
you do it over and over and over again
and there's a better way forward you can
put those things down in your life you
could decide today that you were born to
do something great you could set aside
this weapon that you keep using against
yourself to hold you back from your joy
from your passion from your achievement
from all the goodies in life you could
decide today just intentionally to set
this weapon down whatever it is
something from your childhood a divorce
a business failure something you're just
not proud of that you've done
set it down stop using it as a weapon
against yourself and realize that
happened for you and not to you i'll
prove it to you i'm a big believer and
fake it till you make it
i don't want you seeing you know people
say well social media is so full of like
these fake lives
people have always lived fake lives i
was living a fake life way before social
media came along
in fact when i became an entrepreneur i
wanted to be somebody so bad i wanted to
be rich so bad i wanted to look i
thought if i don't look successful no
one's gonna listen to me who's going to
listen to a young kid in business about
how to save your money when i didn't
have any
that was my own limiting belief what's
yours
you have this kind of convoluted and
limiting belief about why you can't do
something right now that's this your own
bs story you keep telling yourself
how about you just drop that story how
about you just decide it's a lie
even if it is true
i'm not gonna just teach you not to tap
into your pain i'm gonna teach you how
to do it okay i'm not i i teach people
how to change things technically but i
believe in this concept of living
blissfully dissatisfied which means
there's a way most most achievers have
it backwards they think hey if i enjoy
my success i'm going to lose all my
drive
right and then other people that aren't
successful yet haven't reached what they
want or like they delay their bliss
until a destination in the future once i
get this relationship once i make that
money once i get that car once i have
that home then i'll let myself feel
bliss and so i teach you that the
concept is you can live blissfully and
still be dissatisfied your pathway to
changing how you feel about yourself of
getting to the next level is always
giving always giving always giving you
know i have this thing i kind of run my
life through
that kind of is my governor on my life
of what i'm trying to give and when i'm
trying to make a difference for people
and i just have this hallucination i am
a christian and so i believe that
someday when i die there's an accounting
i don't give you i'm actually one of
these very interesting people that i
believe in the quantum field and energy
because i know it exists and i believe
my lord and savior created him that's
you have whatever your belief is is
wonderful i don't preach i just want you
to know i know there's an energy field i
know there's a god
and um
lewis asked me on the show what are
three truths and i said the first thing
is there's a god i just want you to know
that so you believe your beliefs i
respect them i admire my people from
every belief center in the world on my
program but i just want to say to you
this is my prism i live my life through
it governs my decision-making and i make
mistakes all the time one of the cool
things about being a christian is i'm
saved by the grace of god because i know
i'm going to sin that's one of the cool
things about my particular faith but but
the point that i want to make because i
sin all the time i make mistakes all the
time i've already used profanity i think
four times in this talk so i know for
sure i've missed some mistakes but let
me tell you how i govern my life i
believe at the end of my life there's an
accounting and i'm going to sit in front
of my lord and i want to say well done
good and faithful servant but having
said that no matter what your beliefs
are
i think that i actually get to meet
somebody interesting maybe you don't
believe in anything faith-based but i
bet you believe there's a recording
going on in your life someone's paying
attention someone's going to tell the
story of your life maybe your
great-granddaughter will carry the
legacy of your life and what you've done
but someone's paying attention to what
you're doing here you've always had that
sense you've always known your life
mattered you've always known since you
were a little girl that there's
something special you're supposed to be
doing that anxiety that fear you have is
maybe you're not doing it i think we're
all an underdog
i think i think the top ceo on the
planet earth still has that doubt yeah i
don't give a [ __ ] where you're from kobe
bryant michael jordan the best on the
planet we're all underdogs
whether you're underdog because you put
yourself there to be hungry or it's a
real life underdog we're all an underdog
and so this this is about
the mind and people
discovering the mind their own mind and
one thing i know is we all have an
equation
we all have an equation like you know
i'll talk about three point you know
3.14 is pi
there's different equations to figure
out different kind of you know
mathematical problems
we as human beings are mathematical
problems
i cannot give you a book
for every body in this world that's from
my book even though it's one book it's
tailored to
the individual
it's not like you do these five steps
you're good no
i'm helping you figure out your equation
because it's different my equation's
different from your equation what's
going to make you tick what's going to
make you go the distance what's going to
make you go to that spot in hell and say
i love this spot it's okay
that's what this book does it helps you
figure out your 3.14
helps you figure out your mathematical
equation and say oh because once you
figure out the equation in any math
problem
you no longer fail man you got it
figured out i remember we had gone to
mauritius
and when we were in mauritius my team
was also with me and after i did my talk
the host said uh would you like to go
around
okay we can go around we went to a
couple of places we went to the ocean we
went underneath the ocean not scuba
diving we went like 20 30 feet under the
ocean fed fish under the surface of the
water
one place we went to was called the
kasela adventure park
and then our host said would you like to
walk with lions
i said yeah
i'm extremely excited to walk with lions
the
first step
of working with lions was
you had to sign a declaration form
another declaration declaration form
you have to write that the lines you
have to read the clause which says if
the lines pounce on you and kill you it
is completely your response make sure
you hold the stick tight and strong in
your hands and they told us the lions
were brought up with this they came to
this park as cubs and they were brought
up to this idea that whoever holds the
stick in their hands that's a sign of
respect towards them so they won't harm
you if you have sticking hands
my team was looking at me luckily
so we were all holding this uh sticks in
our hands and we were walking
and then you must have seen the video on
youtube this is the video
that i've done on walking with the lions
i'm holding the tails of two lions and
walking this one holding the tails of
flying
i saw a very interesting
thing which in
sanskrit is called
symbol means the glance of a lion
when the lion walks ahead
what the lion does
is
foreign
and gets an estimate of how far it has
come from where it started
the lion turns behind
and sees what all were the hurdles what
all were the obstacles that it crossed
over to come to reach where it is today
and it's incredible the lion looks
behind and said okay i reached here
and then the lion has its eyes
in the front
to see
where it has to go now
how much more distance to cover
what are the hurdles to come on the path
what all the line has to overcome to
reach where it has to reach
this principle is called
when i saw that in mauritius i said this
is such a fantastic thing to apply in
human life as well such a powerful
principle
that when we are in moving on in our
life we need to look back into the past
the past is not a place of residence
the past is a place of reference
past is not the place where we should be
staying
past is the place where we should be
visiting
we have to be a visitor in our past not
a resident of the past
and when we look into the past we can
always look at what went right for us
and celebrate those small victories or
those big victories like the lion when
it walks ahead and looks behind this is
how much distance it has covered this is
how many hurdles it has overcome these
are victories to the lion and there is
celebration
in the year 2021 when you look behind
you may have your small victories your
big victories you may see that something
went right for you you may see that
something went incredibly good for you
some of you probably your relationship
has clicked very well and you're
probably about to get married some of
you the bonding of your affection and
love for each other in your relationship
has gone deeper for some of you you
probably made a good profit in the last
year but some of you probably got a
fantastic job in the last year for some
of you probably cleared your academics
and got an admission in iit mumbai or an
iit kanpur or an iit kharagpur if you
appreciate
it's incredible to look back
and celebrate what went
good
learn what went right
and if we learn from what's went right
and what's going right for us we can
always repeat it from now on in the year
2022 as well we can improvise it we can
enhance it we can we can uh
change the quality of it positively
and guess what
we only add value to what we are doing
and therefore like the lion it's so
important for us to turn behind look
back and reminisce in 2021
what all went right
in the last year
can i learn from what all went right and
invest my time my energy my attention in
doing that again in 2022 yes
there is celebration
but along with celebration ladies and
gentlemen there must also be
deliberation
and what is the deliberation the
liberation of looking behind in 2021 is
what could have gone wrong
yeah
what mistakes did i make
what could i have done better
to be a better person
what could i have done better to be a
better husband a better wife a better
boyfriend a better girlfriend a better
spouse a better uh employer better
businessman a better friend a better me
what could i have done better
for making my work better or by making
my study better what could i have done
better
to keep my mental fitness and my mental
wellness in place what could i have done
better
to lead a better and a happier life
yes
celebration for the victory as the lion
comes ahead overcomes so many hurdles to
come where it is
along with that celebration there is
deliberation people think that
prosperity is just money but really
there's many many other things that come
under this auspices of prosperity
you know you can be very poor in time if
you feel really rushed all the time and
always pressured you have poverty in
your time but if you feel that you have
all the time in the world and that
whatever you want to finish you'll get
done and it will it will all happen then
you're really prosperous in time
and what about success you know if you
feel that it's really way beyond your
reach
then you're never going to get it
but if you feel that you can be
successful whatever that means to you
then that's wonderful that's prosperity
wisdom do you have prosperity and wisdom
do you feel that all the wisdom in the
universe is available to you or do you
think oh i'm just me and i don't know
very much
and you know i can't figure things out
if you feel that you're really connected
with the universe and you really trust
that part of you that's inside then you
can be absolutely prosperous in the
abundance of wisdom and what about love
do you feel that you have an abundance
of love
or are you very poor in love is there
very just a little bit of it in your
life
how about joy
do you feel you're really prosperous and
i have an abundance of joy or is that
something you just allow yourself a
little bit of now and then
and you really are very poor in joy
and then what about beauty
do you see beauty everywhere do you
allow yourself to experience an
abundance of beauty
and of course there's money then there's
money too
you know what do you let yourself have i
like to use that
image a lot of the ocean standing in
front of the ocean with a container in
your hand you know and you're there and
you have this container but what is it
is it a thimble with a hole in it is it
a small cracked cup
is it a mug
is it a vase
but no matter how much you have whatever
your container it is and no matter how
much you're taking from the ocean of
life and even though we're all standing
there we're not robbing each other and
there's plenty for everyone and no
matter how much we take there is no way
we're going to run that ocean drive it's
absolutely impossible and if you can see
yourself standing at the ocean of life
in the same way and remember the
container that you have is your
consciousness
and you can always change your
consciousness
and it doesn't matter if you came from
poverty it doesn't matter where you came
from and it doesn't even matter what
your parents beliefs were because it's
your consciousness and what you're
choosing to think and believe about
prosperity and your ability to deserve
it
is what's going to create it for you
everybody wants to be happy and we're
all looking to be happy and we seem to
have this weird belief that there's some
destination we're gonna get to one day
called happiness but there's no
destination called happiness there's no
terminal you're ever going to arrive at
in your life called this is the happy
place if you want to be happy and why
wouldn't you want to be happy
here's a way to be happy you've got to
be happy right now i see so many people
i'll be happy when my kid can walk my
kid can feed them so i'll be happy when
my kid's gone to be happy when
and if you buy into that i'd be happy
when you're never happy because when
never comes i'll be happy when i'm
married i'm single if i could find a
great person i'd be happy and then you
know what you do you just swap all the
problems of being single to having to
compromise with somebody else because
you have this belief i'll be happy when
so if you want to be happy
here's how to be happy decide to be
happy right now don't do that i'd be
happy when i get to my holiday i'm super
stressed at the airport i'm having a
management but when i get there i'll be
happy because now you've told your mind
that happiness is somewhere you're going
to
tell your mind the truth
i am happy right now i've decided to be
happy in the moment
i'm choosing to be happy you see your
mind is set up to do what you tell it
and every time you say to him i'd be
happy when
it believes that happiness is out there
and you're going there but you might
never get there when you go i'm happy
right now
i'm happy packing i'm happy at the
stress of the airport i'm happy
this minute i am choosing to be happy
then your mind understands the truth
happiness is now you're not going to
happiness you're not looking for
happiness and by the way
nobody else can make you happy while an
amazing partner a great career a
wonderful kid will enhance your
happiness
if you give that to someone else my
partner's going to make me happy having
a baby is going to make me happy having
a great job where i get recognized going
to make me happy getting praise is going
to make me happy you know what you're
doing
you're giving someone else a
responsibility to make you happy and if
you say to them here you go you make me
happy that will work for a while but
then you know what you're giving them
you're giving them power to make you
unhappy
i want a little baby to be happy and i
got it but now that baby is a 14 year
old teenager doesn't want to speak to me
people say oh you know you make me feel
amazing and then the other side of that
is you make me feel so angry and so
lonely and so unimportant don't give
your power to be happy to anyone else
it's up to you
and don't wait to be happy choose to be
happy right now in the moment i mean
look at little children
the rain makes them happy a puddle makes
them happy everything makes them happy
because they live in the moment
happiness is an inside job go inside you
live in the moment i promise you
if you make a decision i'm going to be
happy right now no matter what and
everything i do
you'll train your mind to be happy
next big step forward in life will come
from a big shift in perspective on one
of your beliefs your habits your
routines the results that you're getting
all come from what you believe to be
true about your life and the world and
for you to get different results than
you're getting right now in your life
you're going to have to change your
perspective on one or more of your
beliefs so this topic makes me think
about my favorite comment of all time if
you think about my youtube channel i've
had it for 11 years and i don't know how
many thousands of thousands of comments
my favorite comment of all time was we
profiled a black entrepreneur and
one of the guys in the comments said
growing up my parents
taught me that black people were the
n-word
and you just changed my perspective
today i was willing to learn from a
black man
and
it blew my mind because when i first
set out to make my channel
uh it wasn't really about
race or willingness to learn from other
people it was it was more hey these
people have accomplished success you
should go and learn from them i wasn't
set out to try to solve sexism or racism
or anything uh
so big like that
but what had happened was i had enough
credibility with this person and i
didn't know them from anything they just
watched enough of my videos that then
when i made this video on a black man he
decided you know what i'm gonna give it
a few minutes and that experience
changed his perspective that then will
hopefully go off and change his life
imagine having that belief that then
changes
what kind of ripple effect that has on
the rest of your life and that's what
happens when you get exposed to new
opportunities and new people and new
perspectives you you were raised with a
perspective
your parents your family community a
super isolated perspective that you feel
is right
and many of those things may still be
right for who you want to become
but if you want to have greater success
greater levels of confidence greater
levels of happiness and purpose and
fulfillment than the people around you
you're gonna have to believe something
that's different than what they believe
you're gonna have to surround yourself
with other people who've actually gone
off and done that thing because the
people around you aren't giving you the
thing that you need and so that's one of
my main goals with this channel i know
people come in to learn from people who
are like them you learn from people who
who look like you who might be the same
sex or same gender in the same industry
or use the same language as you
but what i'm really hoping to do as well
is in that process you came for this one
person you came for this one thought or
one idea and i want to expose you to a
whole bunch of different perspectives
all still within the lens of belief
right everything on my channels all of
the channels are always positive it's
always believed it's always optimistic
it's always uplifting but i want to try
to hit you with different perspectives
and angles because eric thomas and jocko
willing are going to yell at you through
something and oprah winfrey and wayne
dyer are gonna hug you through something
and sometimes maybe you need to yell and
sometimes you need the hug but i want to
give you different perspectives to help
you become the best version of you okay
so how do we make the perspective shifts
that we need to make in our life to get
to the spot that we want to be i've got
a three-step process let's go step
number one is learn to learn from people
that you hate
this is one of the most important things
that i can that i can articulate that i
can push you towards find somebody who's
had success
ideally in some kind of related field
but still have some success that you
hate for some reason
and force yourself to learn from them
force yourself to find one thing about
them that you can learn to make you
better at what to do so even looking at
my wall here right i like to tell the
story i've got i've got steve jobs here
and i got my dad here i want to be a
visionary like steve jobs and a father
like my father i don't want to be a
father like steve jobs as a visionary
like my dad right the whole point of
this is for you to be the best you and
for that to happen you pull different
things from different people
you may hate everything about steve jobs
or everything about kanye west at the
back wall there but there's but there's
one thing there's one thing that you can
learn from that person to help you be
better that's often a thing that unlocks
a huge chunk of learning
people typically lock themselves in a
box you've trapped yourself in a box of
learning i'm saying i'm only going to
learn from these kinds of people and so
you get the same kind of messages over
and over and over again but really if
you want to unlock your learning
finding people who you disagree with who
you may hate you may hate a lot about
them but examining how they've had
success a good starting point is the top
tens on my other channel
right it's always positive it's
something that i've learned from if i
can learn from them you could probably
learn from them as well there's one
little nugget out of those 10 rules
maybe that can apply to your life
and when i was learning from kanye west
kanye west was somebody who used to
bother me a lot i saw somebody who's got
a giant ego somebody who who i i didn't
want to be like but i realized you know
what i can learn from this guy
i can learn from this guy i can learn to
think bigger like kanye i can learn to
be a better friend if you know the story
of him and john legend i can learn to be
a better friend like kanye that you
can't really see that picture there but
he's on a radio interview and and he's
saying in that clip
the time is now to be the greatest you i
don't want to sit inside a corporation
for the next 30 years like this is the
time the time is now let's go
i believe that i need to remember that
even more like the time is now
not tomorrow not in three years not next
month like it's right now the time is
now free you can learn that from kanye
right now even if you hate them so step
number one is find somebody who you hate
go to my top 10 channel or my main
channel and go back in the archives and
find somebody who you see their picture
and it drives you nuts already great
force yourself to go learn one thing
from that person that's the starting
point for shifting your perspective step
number two is say it's the best it's the
best this is one of the most valuable
perspective shifts that i think any
human can make is when you're faced with
something that's negative something that
that most people will complain of and
the old you used to complain about you
shifted and say this is the best
this is the best this thing is happening
to me right now this the best this
coronavirus is happening right now for
me it's the best shift your perspective
to say this is the best because what it
does is it moves you from a place of
being complaining and upset and angry
and unproductive into a place of
possibility of resourcefulness of you
now showing to yourself and to the world
what you're capable of and so when i
broke my neck when when there's a fire
alarm going off when we have corona this
is this is how i stay productive this is
how i stay focused this is how i stay
pushing forward when most people are
complaining and negative is i tell
myself this is the best
this is my chance this is an opportunity
i think this is this is the one of the
biggest things that entrepreneurs who've
had the biggest success crush at so many
entrepreneurs have built their
businesses the ones that you look up to
and respect and admire and want to be
like they built their businesses in the
toughest times they built their
businesses in recessions and depressions
why because they said it's the best so
whatever that thing is it feels
overwhelming all all-encompassing
negative in your life stop complaining
about it and say this is the best i'm
growing i'm getting stronger through
this adversity i'm gonna make something
amazing as a result of it and step
number three is the first time yes rule
the first time yes rule is the first
time you get invited to something or an
idea comes your head say yes
most people are in the no business most
people are looking at all the reasons
why it's not going to work and you can't
do this and you have no skills or
abilities or time or resources you're
always finding those we're in the no
business well we can't do stuff we've
told ourselves we can't do these things
just say yes the first time
this is one of the things i love most
about my wife nina is i'll come with all
sorts of crazy ideas and the first time
she'll say yes we'll see right you want
to drive to to boston with with two
videographers in the back and film the
yes perfect you want to go to satguru in
philadelphia and spend two days
meditating yes perfect you even though
you hate the cold you want to sit in an
ice bath with wim hof when he comes to
toronto and filming yes perfect doesn't
mean she's going to do it again
she hasn't sat in a nice bath since but
it's the first time yes the first time
yes rule is one of the biggest mentality
shifts that if you can make you'll open
yourself up to so many more
opportunities i look at dancing for
example china dance salsa right the
other another business that i run and
operate
the number of people who come in
and are scared and
super nervous and it's their first time
dancing ever as an adult
and then you see the shift that they
make and the identity of like i just did
that
i danced i never thought i could dance
and here i got a few basic steps of a
move and if they keep coming back to
keep getting better
a lot of times you're not making the
perspective shift that you need because
you're not trying enough new stuff
because you're in the no business
first time yes rule you get an idea
somebody asks you for something somebody
wants to try something with you yes
first time yes doesn't mean you keep
doing it and as long as it doesn't go
against your ethics or your values don't
go rob a bank because they said first
time yes okay we're not talking about
that kind of stuff
but when you feel a little bit outside
your comfort zone it's like i'm not the
kind of person who does that
first time yes rule just see you might
surprise yourself i will never work in a
relationship i just won't if i'm working
in a relationship something's wrong i'll
work on me
i'll bring my best you bring your best
and we get together and we celebrate it
should work it should work and if it
doesn't
then i'm going to step back and see what
is it about me not you what is it about
me that i need to really look at and
change now
if there's a vibrational match and it
flows and it's fun and you connect on
physically mentally mind body soul you
know that's cool i think that's healthy
but a permission driven person can't be
in a relationship
where you have to keep going back
and and and trying to fix something i
just i just won't do that i just think
that when it when it's right it's right
and i'll know
yeah yeah so i think that i do think
that uh
relationships uh can be easy
and i i do think i i and i think that
they should be
and i and i think that if you're heart
centered
uh that's a different place you meet uh
than than uh other emotions and and and
i and again every time i have a mystical
moment
and i feel that
transcendental love that i don't even
know the word for
every time i have one of those moments i
think i got this all wrong it's just
that it it's it is not chemical it's
electric and you got what all wrong
well the way we view the world the way
we present i mean we don't see things
how they are we see things how we are
you know in every inner experience
that's transcendental experience
enriches circuitry in your brain
experience produces
emotion or energy in the body so you
start having transcendental moments
where you start connecting to that field
its signature is love i mean but not
love like a love for your puppy
it's this is like this is like an
arousal this is i don't know the other
word but spiritual arousal yeah and we
have we have the evidence we can say
oh watch this watch this person's brain
and scientists are studying our work
i'll say oh um watch she's gonna pop in
a few minutes what do you mean just
watch she's gonna pop and all of a
sudden this person goes into an arousal
the sympathetic nervous system is so
switched on but the arousal isn't like
an arousal that from the environment
that produces anger or aggression or
fear anxiety or pain or suffering that's
survival in the environment that
produces the arousal this arousal is
coming from energy in the body that's
moving up into the brain and
the arousal is bliss arousal is ecstasy
the arousal is freedom
but it's it's it's not chemical it's
it's you'll feel it in every single cell
in your body now here's the outcome of
that
the outcome of that is that when you
open your eyes
and some conditioning some layer has
been removed
your spectrum of the way the world looks
broadens now because now you're wired to
perceive what's always existed
but you didn't have the circuits in
place to perceive them so then it's the
inner experience that literally trans
transforms our experience of the outer
world and so
when you start having moments where you
hit that kind of frequency or you have
those moments of love
you're less dependent on anyone to bring
you happiness
you're okay you can love the person for
their flaws
because you can see a part of yourself
you used to be that you no longer aren't
instead of judgment you have compassion
and you can encourage and and and
communicate from from a level of
connection instead of intimidation or or
competition or however relationships
work the person's doing the vision board
and they're saying when i get my new car
i get my new house i get my new
relationship
then i'm gonna feel so great now that
well then they're back to the program
waiting for it to happen
for them to feel the emotion they're
believing their outer world has to
change in order for them to feel better
there's there's no
effect of drawing the experience to you
with that way
so the person has to use those tools
to get them into the emotional state
for them to feel like it's already
happened now think about this
if you get up from
a creative process
and you feel grateful
you feel a love for life you feel a joy
for existence
you feel a passion
to
for the moment
uh
you will not be looking for your future
because you'll feel like it's already
happened
it's the moment that we start feeling
those self-limiting emotions that we
feel separation and then we start
looking for it again well then if you're
waiting you're not creating you're
you're in separation again so then yeah
so then
whatever it takes for you to move into a
state of being and what is a state of
being
thoughts are the vocabulary of the brain
feelings are the vocabulary of your body
how you think and how you feel creates
your state of being so then if you wake
up in the morning and you
come come back to your senses with a
clean slate and you say i don't feel
anything you say well let me start
thinking about all the problems in my
life well all those problems are
connected to different people or
different objects of things at different
times and places the moment you remember
your problems a memory is a record of
the past you're thinking in the past
every one of those problems has an
emotion associated with them so all of a
sudden you start feeling unhappy you
start feeling bitter you start feeling
frustrated so now your body's in the
past so then most people then
create a state of being that's connected
to their past and if they're in the
familiar past
then they are going to crave the
predictable future and they're going to
fall back into routine
so then
we want people then to get very clear on
that vision of their future however they
do it and begin to combine that clear
intention with an elevated emotion and
the stronger the emotion they feel
from the vision they're creating the
more altered they feel inside of them
the more they're going to pay attention
to the pictures in their mind and now
they're remembering their future and
biologically it's exactly the same as
remembering your past in fact if you're
not being defined by a vision in the
future it means you're making your past
more real than your future you're
falling in love with your past you're
more in love with your past than you are
with your future that you're believing
in your past more than you're believing
in your future when you get to that
moment
where you have that feeling
that's your compass
because that feeling is going to drive
your behaviors it's going to drive more
of those thoughts and when you feel that
feeling and it's visceral
no person
no thing no experience will stand in the
way between you and that vision and and
you will be initiated
in by the universe into wealth you will
be initiated into health you'll be
initiated into freedom those people
all those people that have healed
themselves of all those different health
conditions
they are so humble
and so happy and they feel so great that
they would never trade this feeling
because of what you thought of them they
they've left that program behind a long
time ago they actually don't care how
you think of them they they actually are
so happy with themselves
that they're no longer dependent on
anything outside of that now i think
that's a really important moment because
that's the moment we give people
permission in our lives to do the same
right and i think that more and more
people are beginning to figure that out
let's demystify meditation because it
has so many stigmas around it close your
eyes retreat from your life
disconnect from your body disconnect
from your environment disconnect from
your schedule and just give yourself an
hour or 45 minutes or 20 minutes because
when you invest in yourself you invest
in your future and when you believe in
yourself
you believe in possibilities and when
you believe in possibilities you believe
in yourself and if you don't believe in
possibilities then you don't believe in
yourself and you don't believe in
yourself you don't believe in
possibilities so then but if you have a
community a living organism yeah where
it's becoming the new normal yes and you
want to join that living organism and
you want to you want to be a part of
that and and every every stride you make
feeds the living organism every stride
every effort you make
to connect is is amazing because
that which we are seeking is seeking us
it's not like
it is it matches our efforts and so then
when when people have that
uncompromising will
the same way that they go shopping for a
dress or a pair of earrings or go to the
gym and work out with the same intensity
with the same passion
come up against themselves and just say
when the body's going given everything
it has it's when you say that's all you
got that's it that's all you're going to
put out to
i'm ready yeah and so then
when you start overcoming that yeah the
side effect of it is that all of a
sudden you're happy for no reason
and you're less seduced in believing
that something else you need something
outside of it outside of you to make you
feel better all of a sudden you're
feeling better every day
without anything outside of you
and now all of a sudden you start
showing up unpredictable in your life
you're saying that ed guy he's different
he's on a different medication
but in actuality you're just freer right
and so so then as we begin to remove
these layers that stop the flow of the
divine in us that in essence in us the
side effect is we become more willful we
become more mindful we become more
conscious we become more loving it's
it's it's nature you know it's just it
just becomes becomes who we are at the
end of the day if you really wanted to
be wealthy say
how did i do today did i make the right
choices was i ethical was i purpose
driven was i was i was am i interested
in making a difference was i fair was i
tempered
did i really think before i spoke what
what did i remember reading about that
book about that person that did it how'd
i do
and if you said i did i fall from grace
when did i lose it
okay
i want that opportunity again
i want another shot at that and i'm
going in this way what would love do in
this situation what would greatness do
and now you you evolve your experience
and somehow there's a door there's an
opening something shifts something's
changing and now here we go we climb
another ladder and then all of a sudden
there's another challenge and then
people who finally arrive at their
abundance they could care less if
they're abundant they're already knowing
that they've earned the right for it so
so there's sometimes a shortcut in the
process yeah
if we're if we really learn and we
really get it but the trial and error is
so
important because
not only is the person earning the right
to be wealthy
but they're earning the right to live in
worthiness worthy to receive like hey
you people people come to our work all
the time for a lot of reasons and one of
the common reasons is they want to get
healthy yeah and in their own because
they're dealing with a very serious
health condition and i always say the
same thing to them
stop wanting to be healthy learn the
formula yeah on how to get healthy learn
the formula on how to heal and the
healing will be the side effect of it if
you're obsessing about why am i not
healed you're still the old person
you're gonna become that person every
day right
turns out that when you sit down
and the people that we interview that
have had significant changes
when it's no longer about their health
but they are they are out of the
bleachers and they're on the playing
field and they are coming up against the
belief like one lady said god i i always
thought that
this work really worked that this these
concepts are the truth but i never
believed it worked for me and i was in a
car accident in a wheelchair and then
she made the decision that she was going
to overcome that belief now it was no
longer about her healing it was about
overcoming the belief but she overcame
the belief and showed up every day for
herself when you believe in yourself you
believe in possibilities when you
believe in possibilities you got to
believe in yourself you don't show up
for yourself
you don't believe in it yeah and and
that's why people don't do the work i
mean if you you believe that your
thoughts created reality
you would show up every day and create
and so a lot of people believe in their
past more than they believe in their
future a lot of people fall in love or
more in love with their past or romance
their past instead of romance their
future or love their future it's it's
that simple so
the initiation process of life is always
going to be there you're always going to
be challenged if if you want to be a
master well then you better learn how to
heal someone else and you're going to
fail a lot of times and if you think
that you're a failure then you'll quit
but if you feel like you just didn't
quite ding it yet and you show up again
to just ding it and you keep evolving
your experience and go deeper how much
more can i open my heart how much more
can i surrender into this infinite field
how much more can i become can i walk is
it with my eyes open people
do meditations and they have great
meditations me included
and then you get up you open your eyes
and you're back in the program and
people want to know why they haven't
healed and we have testimonies of people
they're speaking the truth they said
my ms
my rheumatoid and my lupus never went
away
i had great meditations i felt better
and then i realized with my eyes open i
was still that person
and now
next level they're in the game catching
themselves or catching how they speak or
watching how they think they're not
letting their body fall in the same
emotional state to put them in the same
past experience that the body's
believing it now this is the this is the
great part and when the person
finally breaks through from the chains
and there's a different consciousness of
freedom that happens
they look back at their past
they want to change one thing in their
past because it brought them to that
present moment that's the path no longer
existing that's the freedom so is it
worth the effort yeah it's no longer
about healing it's no longer about
abundance it's about who you're becoming
the way to this higher place within
ourselves
is understanding two very important
words
these words are the basis for uh
a children's book that i've just done
called i am why two little words mean so
much
any moms right here in the front your
mom here would you like to have this for
your baby
you're welcome god bless you namaste
so
let me just take you back
for a few moments here
back um
back before lao tzu
now lao tzu was here on this planet at
the time of the warring states in china
in 500 bc
approximately the same time that the
bhagavad-gita
was also being created in india
the song of the lord
800 years eight centuries
before that
thirteen hundred years before the birth
of christ
comes
one of the most ancient if not the most
uh ancient spiritual texts extant on the
pre on the planet today
it's called the torah
the first five books of the old
testament
in the second book of the torah
exodus
moses
is
well you know the story of moses but if
you don't let me refresh you
at the time of uh
moses's birth the pharaoh
who had held so many of the israelites
captive and enslaved
had ordered that all male babies to be
born
of uh
from israelite mothers because he had
heard that there was someone coming
that could be a danger to his
power he ordered that all male babies be
be executed
well
moses's mother
gave birth and she just couldn't stand
the idea of this baby being
killed by the soldiers
so she wrapped him up in a blanket
and put him in a basket
must have been waterproof
and floated him down the nile
moses
this little baby was discovered
by
a woman
who um
captured him picked them up and fell so
in love with him that she decided to
raise him as her own
it turns out that this was the daughter
of the pharaoh
so
moses grandfather is the pharaoh who has
ordered him to be killed but he doesn't
know this
at about the age of
18 moses gets into a fight
and with one of the people one of the
soldiers who is
trying to
be uh
trying to actually punish and abs and
kill one of the israelites and so moses
fights him and kills him
and has to run away because he knows
what his punishment will be
he runs away
to the sinai
and for the next 40 years he is a
shepherd he marries a woman named
zappara they have all of these children
he's a shepherd he's out wandering about
according to this ancient text
one day
he comes across a bush
a burning bush
but the bush is not being consumed it is
just continuing to burn
and he looks at this and suddenly the
bush begins to speak and as legend tells
us this is god speaking to moses
and saying to moses um
i have uh i have some instructions for
you
i
i'll give it to you the way it is
written
i just love this
so god calls out to moses from this bush
and says moses moses
and moses responds with the words here i
am this is the first words he speaks to
god
do not come closer he said take your
sandals off your feet for the place
where you are standing is holy ground
then he continues i am the god of your
father the god of abraham the god of
isaac the god of jacob moses hid his
face because he was afraid to look at
god
so god gives him this instruction you
are to go and free the people of israel
so moses says to god
who am i
that i should go to pharaoh and that i
should bring the israelites out of egypt
he answered
i will certainly be with you
and this will be the sign to you that i
have sent you when you bring the people
out of egypt you will all worship god at
this mountain
then moses asked god if i go to the
israelites and say to them the god of
your fathers has sent me to you and they
ask me what is his name
what shall i tell them
now the only place in all the spiritual
texts where god gives his name
is right here in this passage
same name that you have
god replies to moses i am
that
i am
this is what you are to say to the
israelites i am has sent me
to you
god also said to moses say this to the
israelites
yahweh the god of your fathers the god
of abraham and this is my name forever
this is how i am to be remembered in
every
generation to come
which is our generation
all right
so
the name of god
is i am
that
i am
now
every time
you use the name
i am
you are using the name of god
how do you use this name
do you say
i am sick
many of you know that i have been
diagnosed with leukemia
and i generally start out my talks by
saying
i am
well
i am perfect health
i am that
i am
that is my affirmation
that is how i live that is how i breathe
that is how i believe
now
in the book of joel
there's a line
that says
let the weak man say
i
am
strong
now what i want
one of the things that i want to leave
you with here and the time that i have
with you today
is for you to become conscious
of how you use this term i am
i have a cd
along with my friend james twyman
that is
what they did with this is it comes from
the moses code which is a book i
encourage you to look at by james twyman
and what they did is they took the sound
in hebrew
of the letters that mean i am that i am
supposedly this is what
god said to moses
and they have
associated the sound with what those
letters meant back thirteen hundred
years before the birth of christ or
three thousand three hundred years ago
and come up with the sound
the sound is a meditation that i do
every day
and what i recommend that you do
you want this don't you
oh you have it oh you have it great all
right all right you got
it so what i encourage you to do in
terms of manifesting before i get into
the principles
is
to take out a piece of paper sometime
when you're at home and it's
it sounds like a silly thing to do but i
want you to do it i want you to write at
the top of that page the word that
t-h-a-t that
okay
and under that
heading
whatever it is that you would like to
attract or manifest into your life
i would like you to just write that down
all right so if it's a job that you want
if it's a relationship that you want if
it's a uh
a healing that you want if it's a
abundance that you want to attract into
your life whatever it is
just place it underneath that
and come to a place in your life
where it is spoken about in the book of
romans in the new testament
he calls those things which do not exist
as though they
did
you must be able to get to this place in
your life
where you don't use the evidence of your
senses
what your eyes tell you what your ears
tell you
what your stomach tells you
what you see written down what the
internet tells you
you want to be able to be in a place
where you are living from the end as if
what you would like to manifest is
already there
to make a present a future dream a
present fact you must assume the feeling
of that wish as already being fulfilled
i'm saying this is a time more than ever
that you want to begin to inoculate
yourself with positive words coming to
conventions showing up on meetings being
on the calls to make yourself
unstoppable to get out of your mind the
polluting negative thoughts that's
causing most people to go through life
being stuck because they're volunteer
victims somebody said that many people
died at age 25 and don't get buried
until they're 65 because they got so
much garbage in their minds you are here
because you've got a clear vision of
what you want and where you're going
give yourselves a round of applause
come on bring energy level up yes
yes
you want more
you want more
you're different
you're different than everybody else
don't worry if they don't get it don't
try and convince people to do this
business a person convinced against
their will is of the same opinion still
you are not like everybody else you can
walk outside and find pigeons but if
you're looking for eagles it's going to
take you a minute you are different it's
lonely at the top how many of you know
it's lonely at the top raise your hands
it's lonely at the top but you eat
better that's what i'm talking about
you're different one great entrepreneur
said i choose not to be a common man
it's my right to be uncommon if i can i
seek opportunity not security i do not
wish to be a kept citizen humbled and
dull by having the state look after me i
want to take the calculated risk to
dream and to build to fail and to
succeed i refuse to live from hand to
mouth i prefer the challenges of life to
the guaranteed existence the thrill of
fulfillment to the still calm of utopia
i will never cower before a master nor
been to any threat it's my heritage to
stand a wreck proud and unafraid to face
the world boldly and say this i have
done you showed up because you're
building a business that you can stand
and say i did this i did this this is my
dream give yourselves a round of
applause
yes
yes yes
yes
we live in a world where we're told more
about our limitations rather than our
potential how many have you ever been
told that you couldn't do something
raise your hands please
mit did a study that if i say to you you
can't do that
that 16 people have to come along and
say you can do that you can do that you
can do that to neutralize that and the
17th statement that you hear you can do
it will be the one that will finally
stick
so you have to watch who's speaking into
you
you've got to begin to monitor your mind
and and you've got to begin to literally
be proactive in programming yourself to
success be not conformed to this world
be it transformed by the renewing of
your mind you've got to take
responsibility to make that happen
and as you begin to do that you'll begin
to see some incredible changes in your
life i understand now when earl
nightingale said all of us are self-made
but only the successful will admit it
as you begin to look at your dreams and
look at your goals write this down make
know your vitamin
see most people stop short of their
dreams and park and get off the highway
of life because of the rejections of
life you will always be rejected
it's no big deal
jack canfield said rejection is a myth
it's not like when somebody says no and
then they slap you
no just you know to me make know your
vitamin get excited about the no why
because every time someone says no that
brings you another step to a yes you're
getting closer trust me you will win if
you don't quit
you will win if you don't quit even a
broke clock is right twice a day
one of the things i have realized and
many of us have
that
if you want something out of
life if you want to change yourself
if you want to acquire something if
there's some goal that you want to reach
that is really not easy as some people
will make us feel
that living a dream
changing your behaviors overcoming
negative habits it's challenging
it's hard
that living alone is just very difficult
and once we begin to come to grips with
the fact that living is difficult
life is very challenging i heard a song
once by a guy named dimples call
if it ain't one thing it's another
i say to you if it ain't one thing it's
12 others
always something you will never ever
have a problem-free moment in life
somebody said that i like this that do
you either in a problem or just left one
or hit it toward what
anybody found that to be so raise your
hand if you know what i'm talking about
i mean there's always something
so how do we begin to nurture that
hunger what are the characteristics or
the qualities of people that are hungry
what will it take for me to get some of
the things that i want
and being hungry for those things number
one you've got to work on yourself
it's very important that you engage in
an ongoing process to develop you spend
more time on yourself than what you've
been spending
it's very important you owe that to
yourself i was reading a book by
augmentino called the university of
success read one line gave me a chill i
didn't have to read anything else in the
book he said many of us never realize
our greatness because we become
sidetracked by secondary activity
we spread ourselves too thin
don't know how to say no
and we find ourselves doing all kinds of
things and never ever have time to do
those things that we need to do to work
on ourselves and then there goes the
second that goes another second there
goes another second and we can't stop
and hold time and before you know it you
wake up one day and you're behind on
your dreams and your bills
[Applause]
so decide that you're going to take some
time to work on you that you deserve
that
from yourself that your life deserves
some prime time
because you are creating your own
production as michael todd would say you
are the star of your show you are the
director you are writing the script
and you will determine whether your life
is a smash
office hit or flop
you determine that because you made it
this far in a video i want to celebrate
you most people start and don't finish
most people never actually follow
through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want 60 minutes to start your year off
right check the video right there next
to me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there self love
is no longer about pleasure or having a
car it's something that you're
cultivating within you so then imagine
we have research to show and this is
such a this is such a
duality